déjà
e
pour se défendre en cas d'attaqué ou
pour s'entretenir les arts martiaux sont
des disciplines privilégiée dans ses
cours éric charland enseigne plusieurs
techniques de combat réunis en un seul
et même art martial le peuple kg c'est
un art martial de synthèse qui fait la
synthèse donc des arts martiaux d'orient
et les sports de combat de l'occident on
a évidemment tous les arts martiaux
japonais aussi jujitsu jitsu grappling
donc là c'est une forme propre à l'école
on à la pratique des armes les scream à
tout d'eau qui vient d'en plutôt des
philippines que des arts
entre autres le kobudo d'okinawa y un
mais aussi tout ça donc toujours formulé
avec des principes communs qui
permettent de passer dans la martiale un
autre sans avoir besoin de juxtaposer
les techniques un tour du monde des arts
martiaux qui passe aussi par la russie
avec le sistema du mma ou le krav maga
israélien eric a créé l'homme qui doit
il y a trente ans tous les jours je
pratique entre 3h et 4h pour faire mes
propres recherches et c'est vrai que la
force de pratique et de recherche etc
j'ai pu déjà haut niveau c'est le
défense pur illuminés des techniques qui
ne fonctionnait pas j'ai beaucoup
pratiqué les principes sol les principes
communs aux arts martiaux niveau de la
biomécanique et des principaux signes
vers celles comme la stabilité le
l' équilibre la globalité du corps le
relâchement musculaire la respiration
aujourd'hui son académie et présenta
plaisir d'autres clubs existent à poissy
mais aussi au canada et au congo 450
adhérents pratiquent ces disciplines
passionné d'arts martiaux depuis l'âge
de 5 ans le plaisir wwa est aussi tombé
amoureux de cette philosophie qui prône
l'épanouissement personnel et le
bien-être
ce soir-là cours de tai chi qui débute
toujours par un moment de méditation
[Musique]
se recontacter au niveau de son
intériorité sert d'être plus en lien
avec soit lâché peut-être un peu plus
sur les sur tout ce qui peut nous gêner
c'est les schémas du passé les scénarios
du passé donc on va réellement apprendre
à apprendre un petit peu de distance à
changer de rapport aux événements que
l'on vit pour vivre plus dans l'instant
dans le présent cheminée pour se
réaliser et puis le sentier mais en
général je dire dans la même idée il a
également créé l'ostéo qui nergie ainsi
que différents programmes de remise en
forme comme le calice techniques
fonctionnelles movement autant de
méthodes accessible au plus grand nombre
eric souhaite transmettre ses
compétences et accompagner ses élèves
dans leur évolution
c'est vrai que ça donne une position de
force intérieure quelque part face aux
événements de la vie sire que même si on
a des du stress des peurs des émotions
et cetera bon c'est vrai qu'on va quand
même gérer les choses à apprendre à
gérer dans l'accueil et puis en général
on va on va toujours travaillé pour
évoluer et pour continuer d'avancer à
temps
les objectifs que l'on s'est fixés dans
notre propre ville un enseignement
physique et spirituelle des stages de
kido ou de jahia yoga sont organisées
régulièrement pour découvrir ou se
perfectionner